this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbusters
summer in an era where Michael Bay blew
up alcatraz and roland emmerich blew up
the world Kevin Costner only needed one
bomb to blow up Universal in Waterworld
enter the watery world known as
Waterworld a post apocalypse where
everyone looks like they sleep in
SpongeBob's dumpster full of makeshift
vehicles resource hoarding warlords and
here I'll save you some time
it's Mad Max but wet
[Music]
and terrible
Geils kevin costner is the Mariner a
hero with all the charm of a guy getting
hit with a bucket of water between tags
which to be bare he was he's a man of
few words
like really few words
my boat in fact nobody gets to talk when
he's around me you've talked along don't
shut off you're too loud try sitting
still after all the time did you say
something
but this mysterious stranger has a
mutant power of being super good and
rope stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
watch this fish man out of water on a
mission to save a girl from the only guy
in the movie who knows how silly it is
well and on the way our heroic
embodiment of Florida will learn to do
the right thing kid we got a pitch over
the side what eventually any time now
right after this
eventually yep
that's the guy we're rooting for and
drinking his own pee yep just as soon as
he's done gargling his own piss I'm
pimping out her mom half an hour just
gonna throw this out there are they
better off with Dennis Hopper at least
they get a jet ski so take a shot of
hydro top off your go juice and count
your chance to revisit the first and
last aqua Punk epic that may have been
the laughingstock of Hollywood for being
an expensive set sinking vanity project
but still had the seed of something
really cool just cut out all the
terrible dialogue better not screw up my
short game most of the characters the
story and do 20 minutes of great
practical effects and real live action
scenes perfect oh man now I want a
churro
starring Merman dad Murr man me as soon
as I'm home from work Mariah Nanoha
alone Oh deep very deep cheesy writer
bordering you get one everything's here
when I get back sixty-two Chin's have
your chicks you the man with the dirt
pure dirt Wow horses boats and hoes and
oh man keep the politics out of my water
world wild wild wet the Mariner may have
taught her to swim but Napoleon Dynamite
taught her to love have you still not
seen the documentary we made about
Twilight fans who are still going hard
in 2019 no will click here now a Robert
Pattinson won't come to my birthday
party you're breathtaking you're all
breathtaking banner gave me the best
present I could ask for a taco new
master